are you thirsty
i think i could spare a bit more
hey guys pete here today i'll be talking
about raised by wolves season two
episode three good creatures marcus is
increasing the numbers for his new
church the hunt for number seven
continues and father's million-year-old
android restoration project is really
starting to get interesting i'll be
recapping everything that happened in
the episode right after this quick
spoiler warning if you haven't watched
raise by wolves season 2 episode 3 then
this video won't be for you and with
that out of the way let's get into it
episode 2 ended with a conflicted mother
setting out to kill her natural child
the completely unnatural hybrid synth
organic flying serpent the third episode
continues there with her toting a
harpoon gun heading towards the
mountains she comes across father who's
on his bait mission with the mithraic
prisoners and doesn't see the point of
that considering that she's told
everyone that she'll kill the serpent
herself he argues that they should use
everything at their disposal to keep
their children safe and they have a nice
moment where he reassures her that she's
good that the children need her and for
whatever it's worth so does he in their
tank marcus decima and tamerlane are
also looking for the serpent they start
broadcasting a sound which they think
will attract it and that brings them
into contact with father who when he
hears that activates the lores in the
mathrax hats they all come together and
we get a showdown between marcus and
father when the latter refuses to let
the prisoners go and says that he
wouldn't hesitate to detonate them while
they're discussing that they realize
that father would have been destroyed in
the process of doing his job of being
the shepherd the blast radius of the pax
is bigger than the range of the staff so
whenever he did his job he would also be
destroyed eventually father decides to
attack him and you see that marcus is
deceptively powerful because of mother's
eyes he's able to repel the shock from
the staff and then defeats father by
knocking him down and then using that
same electricity to disable him the
whole time we see that the veins on his
face are pulsing and that just
reinforces that he is basically
superhuman he frees the mithraics and
offers to allow them to come to his new
church and they're all pretty much on
board except for lucius who spits in his
face and refuses to join them elsewhere
campion and paul get verrill back to the
cave she tells them that it's a church
after paul notices the saul invictus
symbol on the wall as she's repairing
her legs she mentions that her mother
broke her neck once but when camping
asked more about that she says that the
story is restricted and she makes a
point that the original virile was sad
and that mimicking that strains her
systems campion is very curious and they
seem fascinated with each other as they
talk which seems to set up a future
relationship on her journey mother comes
across the cloaked trap that cleaver and
his men set up and she trips it again
she tells them that they don't need to
worry about it because she plans to kill
number seven she believes it's nesting
on top of a nearby mountain and is
planning on going up after it when he
checks with the trust it instructs
cleaver to go with her they stop at a
point for a conversation where she asks
him why he doesn't get his eyes fixed he
wears glasses and she says they belong
to someone else didn't they which feels
like a point that might come back up
later he doesn't answer he says that he
knows better than to let a necromancer
into his head he points out that the
trust is different because it wasn't
built as a weapon and she reminds him
that her primary role now is to be a
caregiver she makes her way up a sheer
cliff and at the top finds number seven
she has her gun out but as it approaches
her and looks at her she puts it down a
bird flies by which she catches and then
uses that as an offering but finds out
that number seven isn't interested she
realizes it doesn't want blood and puts
it together that it's an herbivore when
she sees it eating the pumpkins
back at their dwelling holly and hunter
bring father back the kids are initially
upset that he was going to use the
prisoners as bombs they worry that he's
looking at the mithraics in a way that's
different from other human beings
tempest points out that he's just trying
to protect them and then she tells him
that mother was there but she went to
feed the serpent and he gets worried
immediately at the same time paul and
campion return and paul tells them that
they have to keep what they saw a secret
because marcus isn't hurting anyone and
someone needs to keep the religion alive
father leaves to go to see what's going
on with mother for himself you see that
the colonists are upset because they
haven't killed number seven yet and
father offers to do it because he feels
like it's a threat to their children
mother explains that she checked its
scales that it wasn't in the acid water
and that her instincts are telling her
to protect it father points out that she
was manipulated into carrying it and
that it's more akin to a parasite than a
child and mother disagrees saying that
it's part of her so they are at odds
here and she did promise on their
partnership that she would take care of
the situation but now she thinks she can
control it this all angers father and he
decides to go to his shed where he
realizes that he cares too much about
her happiness he can't go against her
and kill number 7 and thinks to himself
love be the death of us all some of his
feel blood drips on the android skeleton
and he notices that something starts to
happen it starts to change it's almost
as if it's growing and we hear him say
to himself that it seems mother isn't
the only one capable of creating life
the ancient android is really starting
to take shape later when you see it
after he goes through all the fuel blood
he can find its face is protected by
something that he can't remove and
inside the chest cavity you can clearly
see that something's growing there he
goes out looking for more robot milk and
he's stopped when he tries to walk away
with what he thinks is some and sue has
to intervene to vouch for him with an
atheist that tried to stop him she asked
him about the injuries that he got from
marcus and also tells him that he's
stolen fruit juice and reuse containers
and tells him the good stuff is locked
away in the tarantula he goes and gets
hunter and they go to try to obtain more
they end up meeting a new character
named nerva who trades things she's
someone who can find things in the
colony and she's not interested in
trading him for relics the metal cards
because she has a bunch of them and
nobody wants them she does have an offer
though where he can earn five gallons of
fuel blood by fighting a scary looking
industrial android named billy when he
hears the terms of the fight that he
just has to knock billy down before
billy knocks him down he decides to go
through with it and it's pretty chaotic
he ends up winning an impressive fashion
and you see that he actually looks
pleased to see that everyone's cheering
for him at the end in her new position
sue is looking stressed the trust wants
her to analyze the samples taken from
the new animal and she tries to resist
this but she's told that it's an organic
synthetic hybrid with strong
weaponization potential she learns that
it's still developing and that it's
approximately six months old with that
she starts to realize that mother is its
mother and later she tries to ask father
if this is the case without actually
saying it you see that campion is drawn
to it he tells mother that he thinks
it's in touch with something that she
can't see and this makes her worried
that he's thinking too much like paul if
he wants to lead the atheist which is
what she wants him to do he's going to
have to stop talking about soul and as
they're having their conversation he
asks her if all androids care how people
look which is obviously related to his
attraction to verrill he also makes a
comment about number 7 seeming jealous
the trust wants to interview paul again
and while they're talking he shows him
mouse the ai asked him if he still wants
marcus dead saying that good things come
to those who tell the truth and he asks
him if he's had any recent contact with
him he says no which is technically not
a lie since they were just at his cave
he did see him though when they were
hiding and still going there is what the
trust was asking him about it ends up
giving him mouse back and tells him that
they are mounting a search and destroy
mission in 24 hours there's a brief
conversation between champion and father
where he says that he can't understand
how marcus could defeat him in a fight
father is nearly indestructible and he
explains to campion that marcus
exhibited strength well beyond a normal
human as they're getting ready to do
their chores paul says that he wants to
warn marcus about the search and destroy
mission they come clean to holly about
visiting the cave with virile and
together they all decide to ditch their
chores and go back there you see that
things are going pretty good with
marcus's new family everyone seems happy
there and with everything that happened
they all seem to be of the mind that he
is the actual prophet marcus and decima
are getting closer we see them kiss and
then varial notices that holly paul and
campion are watching them from a
distance marcus notices too and he
invites them in and you kind of hear the
sound that he emanates as a result of
having mother's eyes inside of him as
the episode comes to an end
things are starting to pick up here
after the transition to this new
location i find father's ancient android
to be the most fascinating thing that's
happening just him having a project is
satisfying and you have to wonder how
mother will react once he brings this
thing back i mentioned being intrigued
by it being a million years old in my
last video and here we see that the way
it's reacting to fuel blood seems to set
it apart from any of the other androids
we've seen before from the trailers
promotional materials and casting
announcements we can put together that
this is the character that's referred to
as grandmother although we'll have to
wait and see how she gets that name it
seems important that father was able to
collect all of her pieces in the same
general area in the official podcast
when he was asked if there was one thing
he would plant in the minds of viewers
the showrunner aaron guzikowski said
that he would just say pay attention and
look around at everything in this
environment for where things end up the
kind of big twist of the season he said
it's all right there for all to see he
also confirmed that there are seeds
inside the dodecahedron that paul found
which was next to a tree and what you
could definitely describe as a garden
the tree of life a serpent the beginning
of a new civilization there's a lot of
genesis slash garden of eden vibes in
this tropical zone i thought the trust
interviewing paul felt pretty ominous
considering that it felt like a test we
know that he at least stretched the
truth if not flat out lied and it seems
pretty likely that the trust will know
that as well and this ai doesn't seem
like something that you would want to
cross it also stood out to me that when
the bot was trying to get sue to go to
work that it said that number seven had
great weaponization potential the end
made it seem that paul is more attracted
to marcus than he wants to believe
considering their history this could be
related to the necromancer eyes effect
which is another thing the showrunner
confirmed is happening he somewhat
superpowered after ingesting them which
was clear in his fight with father but
it's also what's drawing people to him
either way though it makes sense that
even though paul might be conflicted
about what happened to his real parents
he would still be more drawn to marcus
rather than the atheist colony he's been
cruel and unaccepting of sue but he
views her as impure while he sees marcus
as essential to keeping the religion
alive and i do find it interesting that
they both independently think that
they're the one that the prophecy is
about it wasn't terribly surprising that
mother wasn't able to go through with
killing number seven and i guess you
could see where she's coming from and
thinking it's not a threat her internal
conflict all checks out and father's
concerns are valid at the same time you
can't help but notice that she's keeping
their connection a secret sue is
certainly picking up on it and campion
was pretty close to putting the pieces
together too i'm guessing the fact that
camping and number seven are actually
brothers will be important and the whole
idea of mother and father keeping the
secret might come back to bite them it
still seems like it could do a lot of
damage if it had a reason to whether
it's a meat eater or not and now i'm
curious to see what it was that pulled
the colonists into the acid ocean
there's a lot of interesting stuff going
on and i think that's a good place to
leave things let me know in the comments
what you thought about this episode what
you think about the season so far what
series do you have going on and where do
you think things are heading there were
a lot of little things in this episode
that feel like they're going to come
back up later like cleaver's glasses
lucious and marcus's conflict father
getting pumped up from the crowd
cheering for him verrill's mention of
decima breaking her neck and marcus and
everyone else thinking he's blessed by
soul when there's an explanation to
what's really going on with him please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon